[Musique]
sébastien où aller a appris seul à
réparer les flippers ans les
collectionnant celui c'est mécanique il
date de 1976 et n'a pas fonctionné
pendant 30 ans grattez les contacts un
parent changer les bobines et des
lumières l'ancien facteur devenu
réparateur à travailler dessus de 20
heures pour les redonner vie
on a du sens euros pour une révision
totale avec le changement des élastiques
le traitement du plateau le polissage du
plateau un voile à l'ensemble de la
réparation des pannes en fait voilà et
puis pour qu'ils soient sont en portions
fonctionnel et plus beau possible bas
par rapport à son état d'origine cette
dépense de plus en plus de particuliers
sont prêts à la faire il faut dire
qu'aujourd'hui un flipper vote entre
1800 et 15000 euros pour les plus
perfectionnés alors forcément sébastien
croule sous les demandes de réparation
le plus difficile c'est de retrouver des
pièces des pièces neuves pour certains
flipper parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
ne sont pas fabriqués ou qui sont
épuisés donc c'est très très compliqué
on est obligés de commander aux états
unis ou en allemagne voilà où même des
fois en australie ça m'arrivait de
commander en australie pour trouver la
pièce vous le décor qui manquent
ses clients ont entre 40 75 ans est un
très fort pouvoir d'achat c'est le cas
d'alain 65 ans passés devant la boutique
par hasard ça représente notre jeunesse
aussi
il est prêt à mettre plus de 3000 euros
pour acheter ce jeu mythique le prix du
souvenir plus que celui du flipper mais
aussi leur est au fond du bar à réviser
et puis en même temps il y en avait un
qui est on avait le copain qui joue au
flipper c'est un cas mais qui on lui
donnait 20 centimes et nous monter le
compteur à scène et nous montait cette
partie parce que j'étais plus doué que
nous ils savaient il savait jouer et
après banques en europe venez jouer
voilà donc on révisait le bac dans même
ton joue au flipper mais voilà ce
nostalgique vie dans le lot trop loin
pour sébastien qui ne livre que dans un
rayon de 100 km autour de romorantin
il veut être certain de pouvoir assurer
les réparations